les visiteurs sont de retour au centre
d'art contemporain de tours consigne
sanitaire oblige ils ne sont pas plus de
30 à la fois une contrainte qui ferait
d'eux presque des privilégiés je suis
enchanté de retrouver le chemin du cc
cod évidemment que j'affectionne et là
comme je disais avec madame notre guide
c'est une c'est une première donc
privilégié certes et on apprécie pour
fêter le retour des amateurs d'art les
conférenciers du cc cod propose chaque
jour une visite à la carte
nous proposons au public gracieusement
un rendez-vous de visites commentées à
16h30 tous les jours ce rendez-vous il
dure environ 30 minutes
il porte sur une exposition de notre
choix de neaves ans est une artiste
québécoise
elle a aujourd'hui une soixantaine
d'années est né en 1957 est sa
spécialité c'est la pratique de l'image
inauguré en février dernier les oeuvres
de dominique blain sont à voir jusqu'en
septembre
les deux autres expositions du centre
sont prolongées vous fait chausser dans
la galerie noir du bâtiment du centre
d'art nous avons fabien verchères qui a
été prolongée un peu plus tard et puis
celle de mathieu dufois au deuxième
étage dans les galeries qui elle sera
prolongée qui devait terminer qui devait
se terminer en juin en juillet nous
jours une nouvelle exposition de vivien
roubaud un artiste français qui vit et
travaille en belgique dans le grand
espace de la nef
en juillet le centre d'art contemporain
à concocter de nouvelles visites
adaptées pour les enfants pour faire de
ces grandes vacances une pause
culturelle et apprenantes